gregory brent dennis signed a plea deal
and will serve three to 10 years for
voluntary manslaughter mary jane
belliesa has reaction now from the
victim's family following the sentences
an emotional day for family members of
susan winters and gregory dennis as he
was taken away in handcuffs when winters
died in january 2015 there was a lethal
amount of oxycodone in her system and a
deadly dose of chemical from antifreeze
the coroner originally ruled her death a
suicide but her family remained
suspicious of dennis after several
stories from the 8 news now i-team
henderson police reopened the case they
found while winters was out from the
antifreeze dennis went to buy the drugs
to kill her his attorney read a
statement from the couple's daughters
supporting their father on the other
side of the courtroom winter's family
members including her mother also spoke
we were 12 and 15 when our mother passed
but we knew the many wonderful qualities
she possessed as well as her flaws
now we are 20 and 22 years old and we
more fully understand the issues our
mother faced
unfortunately many women including us
have similar issues that are difficult
to accept see my daughter has created a
void in my heart that will never be
filled
i miss her every single day
i miss her phone calls holiday meals
shopping trips vacations and simple
conversations about motherhood and life
in general an investigation revealed
dennis struggled with financial problems
and there was a large insurance policy
on his wife the police said the motive
was money reporting from the regional
justice center mary jane bolieza live
local now